All right, let's see what is on people's minds.
Uh, getting to the end of a very, very busy
political week.
We'll go to the phone lines at six one seven,
eight three zero 47 50.
Starting today with our caller from the seven
one four area code color from seven one four.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi, is that me?
Yes it is.
Hi David.
My name is Keandre.
I'm calling from the San Francisco Bay area.
How are you?
Good.
I'm doing well.
Um, it's not a question.
Uh, so I know that, uh, the right, uh, sort
of, they have this thing where, and you talked
about this in your show before where it's
sort of like these little quippy responses
they can throw at ya, you know, Oh, abortion
is murder and yet we're blind.
But we in the left have to do a lot of explaining.
We'll know it's not because science says,
you know, last begins here or there and global
warming.
And I was like, we have to do a lot of explaining.
Do you think the left needs a sort of rebranding?
And if you do, how so?
Like how can we be as quickly as quick to
respond as the right and kind of have that
level of just ease of understanding.
I don't know that the left needs to rebrand.
I think the left needs to become better at
framing.
And George Lakoff has written about this a
lot and he's, he is actually, he has suggestions
about how should the left talk about taxes,
how should the left talk about things like,
you know, using the military around the world
and the context of how the Wright views patriotism
and the left use patriotism.
There are a lot of really good, um, thinkers
on this.
I don't think it's, it's an issue of rebranding.
I think it's just an issue of figuring out
better ways to talk about a lot of this stuff.
And we're even seeing it during the democratic
debates.
I mean, th there the candidates are getting
better, but take for example, this question
of, um, uh, should undocumented immigrants
get free healthcare.
It's like when that comes up, you need to
be ready to take control of the question rather
than just answering it in a particular way.
Elizabeth Warren had one good instance when
she was asked about, you know, this, should
the government be able to tell you what kind
of straw to use?
And she didn't accept the question as asked.
She said, hold on a second.
That's not even the issue.
The issue is actually that that is almost
completely insignificant and really dealing
with the issue of pollution in the environment
and the left needs to retake control of the
conversations rather than to then fall into
what you are correctly pointing out are often
fruitless, nuanced, necessary explanations
that don't really appeal to people who are
less avid followers of politics.
[inaudible] and then another quick little
thing.
Um, so also would like to point out, cause
I thought it was interesting, I was just recently
talking to my uncle on my mother's side and
he was in the military and he often said,
you know, being on the left in the military
is really different because um, you can't
really speak out because you hear your military
buddies, they're all saying no right-leaning
stuff.
And it's kind of difficult being in the West
in the military because it's kind of viewed
as un-American in a way.
And I thought that was interesting to point
out cause I made him, that's what made me
think about the whole rebrand and whatnot.
Yes, that is interesting.
And I a I appreciate you bringing it up.
Keandre appreciate hearing from you.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay, very good.
Take care.